[Applause]
[Music]
for decades the fear of running out of
oil was one of the most recurrent
forecasts and at the same time the one
that generated the most headlines
alarm and controversy was even a course
subject or at least
a warning even in schools do you
remember perhaps this was largely
because the availability of usable
energy sources in the past
was much more limited than it is today
so much so that as the bad omens were
never fulfilled the prophecies were
postponed again
and again and again one day the
long-awaited end of oil would be upon us
the world will run out of oil in 10
years the u.s bureau of maine's
in 1914 the world will run out of oil
in 13 years the us department of the
interior
in 1939 and 1950
the world will run out of oil and other
fossil fuels by 1990.
paul elric the limits to growth in 1972.
the world will run out of oil in 2030
and other fossil fuels by 2050. paul
elric
beyond the limit 2002. as you can see
not a single one nailed
it of course what all these people never
took into account was the technological
evolution that human beings would
continue to nurture over the years
[Music]
and we are not only talking about oil
the fear of running out of an abundant
energy source was a constant among
journalists analysts
and experts of all kinds in fact today
when we talk about fossil fuels what we
usually care about most is pollution but
the truth is that
for years it was not a question of
environmental awareness but of fear
fear of running out of supplies in any
case the point is that we are in the
21st century
and with the exception of nuclear energy
the whole world seems to be moving
towards a future without fossil fuels
the whole world no
not the whole world along the lines of
asterix's village there is one country
populated by
unyielding samurai that is resisting
against all odds in recent years
japan has gone against the global trend
not only has it not reduced its
consumption of fossil fuels it's
actually
increased it
[Applause]
you see 2011 was something of a turning
point for japan the earthquake and the
subsequent tsunami with its devastating
effects on the fukushima nuclear power
plant changed the country's approach to
energy if up to that point
the japanese had embraced nuclear power
suddenly things were different they
wanted to look for alternatives the
fukushima incident resulted in many of
the country's nuclear reactors being
shut down a situation that continues to
this day
obviously all that power had to be
supplied in some other way
yes with renewables but also initially
with oil and gas
lots and lots of gas
so much so that in 2016 primary energy
sources from fossil fuels came to
account for more than 90 percent
of all national consumption in a country
with as few usable natural resources as
japan
this meant that more than 80 percent of
its energy needs had to be covered by
imports
japan is one of the most energy
dependent countries in the world
the thing is that it set off all the
alarm bells in tokyo and it was not just
an environmental issue but also and
above
all a strategic economic and
geopolitical issue for a country like
japan to depend
entirely on the supply of fossil fuels
of foreign origin and brought in by ship
is a huge risk to national security
especially in an era when xi jinping has
turned geopolitics upside down
in this region of the world for years
japanese politicians bet on nuclear
energy
as the best way to gain autonomy but
what happens if you no longer want it or
can no longer count on it electorally
let's just say that nuclear energy is
not exactly the most popular energy
source in japan right now
and precisely for this reason the
japanese all threw themselves into the
development of renewable energies as if
there was no tomorrow especially solar
energy but of course replacing nuclear
energy
is a tall order so the question the big
question on our minds is
what is the solution that the japanese
have put on the table what exactly have
they come
up with do they have any original ideas
[Music]
well although one of the theories may
surprise you one of the solutions to
this whole mess is to become something
like the new gas shakes
yes to become major producers at all
costs but there is one problem they
don't have any gas
at least not what we all know as
conventional natural gas
and right there at this point the time
has come to unveil what could be one of
japan's great strategic gambles
methane hydrate have you ever heard of
this compound i guess most of you
haven't
am i wrong well pay attention because
we're going to tell you what it consists
of
how you can take advantage of it and
what exactly japan has in mind for it
listen up
[Music]
flambel ace
yes you heard it right we haven't gone
crazy not yet
there is an ice that if you hold a flame
to it it ignites
it's called methane hydrate and it is
found in enormous quantities all over
the planet
specifically under the ocean floor and
take note because it is precisely its
location that makes it one of the most
desirable but at the same time
also one of the most controversial raw
materials after all not only are there
unique and fragile ecosystems on the
ocean floor but
extracting raw materials from the depths
is a risky business but to understand
the importance of this resource
we have to put environmental
considerations aside for a moment
and focus on its enormous potential
which i think may surprise you
why well methane hydrate is the most
abundant source of carbon
on earth it accounts for an estimated
one-third of all the carbon on the
planet
and this is a huge deal because
estimates of global methane hydrate
reserves from the us department of
energy
suggest that its energy power could
exceed that of
all other known fossil fuels that is
precisely why china is also testing the
extraction of this resource in the south
china sea and indeed it is something
that beijing could be taking into
account when extending its maritime
claims however we're talking about a
compound
that is highly unstable highly flammable
and particularly sensitive to pressure
and temperature these characteristics
mean
that its extraction is far from being as
simple as traditional mining
that is digging collecting and
transporting it to the mainland
so why are we talking about japan and
not other countries when we refer to
this flammable ice well take a look at
this map for a better understanding
each of the green dots refers to known
deposits of methane hydrate in the world
as you can see
highest known concentration of this raw
material is located precisely around
japan
the japanese coastline is literally
dotted with deposits of this compound
this is largely due to the confluence of
tectonic plates and the huge sedimentary
deposits off its coast
so it's not so bad at least there's
something good about being one of the
most seismic prone
areas on the planet right right
[Music]
well you see in this case the trade-off
is that japan is one of the countries
with the largest reserves of methane
hydrate on the planet to give you an
idea the japanese government estimates
that there are at least 24.7 trillion
cubic feet that's seven
trillion cubic meters of methane hydrate
in offshore deposits in its territory
that could be enough to meet japan's
entire gas consumption for almost a
century and there could be much more
hydrate precisely for this reason there
is little doubt that methane hydrate
extraction could guarantee energy supply
for a very
very long time obviously not only in
japan but let's take a minute because
it's not that simple
the problem is that we still don't know
very well how to take advantage of it
in particular how to extract and process
it well today there are two ways to do
it
one let's call it conventional and
another let's say a little more
revolutionary which is what japan is
trying to develop
the traditional way is to extract this
resource by drilling into the seabed at
depths of about 3200 feet
that's around 1000 meters keep in mind
that the deposits are not in the water
itself but are located
several hundred feet below the seabed
which implies additional complexity
and such high costs that at present this
option is not commercially viable and
then
there is the more revolutionary way
which is what japan is working on
companies like modek and mitsubishi
shipbuilding
are developing extraction vessels that
are capable of safely extracting methane
hydrate deposits closer to shore this
would be done by puncturing the seabed
until reaching the reservoir and letting
the methane hydrate
rise to the extractor vessel which in
turn could rely on other auxiliary
vessels to transport it to shore or even
store it and transform it
into methane gas in situ
seems simple doesn't it well the truth
is that it is not at all the technical
complexity
comes above all as we mentioned before
because of the instability of this
resource and also because of the risk of
contamination
since if it is not done properly high
quantities of methane could be released
into the sea
and then into the atmosphere and
obviously this is not good either near
or far from the coast but near is even
worse
what's more beyond the risks the
extraction itself is technically
complicated let's say that during the
drilling process there is a risk of sand
or anything else entering into the
reservoir through the borehole and that
could destabilize the methane hydrate to
the point of
rendering it unusable anyway that is
what they are working on the goal is to
get gas
gas and more gas and make it as cheap as
possible for the japanese but let's not
miss a key detail here japan aspires to
become a hydrogen producing powerhouse
producing hydrogen precisely from the
gas extracted from methane hydrate
deposits a kind of little red hen
approach
and as we've covered recently in a video
about hydrogen which by the way i'll
link to you in the description the
implications could be enormous but wait
a minute
so long as we are talking about methane
hydrate what on earth is hydrogen doing
here listen up
japan's springboard to hydrogen
well as we told you in the hydrogen
video this fuel can be produced in
several different ways
the most common is to produce it using
coal natural gas or more recently
renewable energies as well well here is
the key to japan's energy intentions
to extract methane hydrate and to use it
to produce hydrogen to give you an idea
one cubic meter of methane hydrate can
produce approximately 160 cubic meters
of methane gas which can then also be
converted into hydrogen in this way
countries with large methane hydrate
deposits such as japan
could move very quickly to hydrogen and
use it as a clean fuel that is not
dependent on imports
[Music]
in fact hydrogen is an increasingly
important pillar of the japanese
government's energy strategy which hopes
to boost hydrogen consumption to over 20
million tonnes by 2050 a relatively high
target
especially if we take into account that
per unit weight the energy output of
hydrogen is three times that of gasoline
but one that will only be possible to
achieve
if production costs can be substantially
reduced thus the japanese government's
plan is to reduce the cost of hydrogen
production from 100 to 20 yen per cubic
meter that is from 91 to 18 cents and to
achieve that goal among other things the
country needs a very competitive energy
supply potentially
methane hydrate not only that but
producing hydrogen from methane hydrate
gas
would be cleaner than from other sources
as methane hydrate emits 30
less carbon dioxide when burned than
coal or oil does
[Music]
the question is will it be possible to
harness methane hydrate on a commercial
scale and will it be economically viable
and then another question is
will the take-off of hydrogen accelerate
thanks to methane hydrates
japan eyes undersea fire ice as source
of clean burning hydrogen
nikai asia as you can see this is the
energy revolution that japan is trying
to enter
[Music]
a strategy that would then be
complemented by carbon capture
technologies in this way japan could
achieve
enormous energy autonomy but will it
ever be feasible that is not clear but
for the record in 2017
the land of the rising sun bridge
managed to extract methane hydrate for
24 days without any technical incident
through his experimental project in the
nankai pit
not only that the government believes it
will be able to get commercial methane
hydrate projects off the ground between
2023 and 2027.
or at least that is what its latest
strategic energy plan says
so do you think that we should take
advantage of the gas that is dormant in
methane hydrate deposits on a massive
scale or do you think that this type of
extraction should not be carried out
under any circumstances due to the
environmental risks involved leave us
your opinion below in the comments and
as always if you found this video
interesting don't forget to like and
subscribe to visualpolitik and once
again
thank you for being there take care and
see you next time